it is money that was supposed to be used
for children instead police say school
staff scammed the system and actually
spent that money on themselves yeah
these are also your tax dollars this is
a story about an alleged theft ring at a
las vegas school the eight news now
i-team first broke at four now we show
you the evidence at the center of it
this is a
very large fraud effect within our
school systems nearly 154 thousand
dollars stolen from a program aimed to
help students police say school
principal victoria welling is accused of
signing off on the scheme here she is in
court thursday she is just as guilty as
the teachers who actually took the
products police say multiple teachers at
legacy traditional schools southwest
academy were stealing the covid 19
relief money the rule one 954 dollar
grant per teacher for a school project
but instead police say teachers used
fake names to get multiple grants each
christopher olmstead once named teacher
of the year is accused of creating 21
accounts with names like chrissy and
christian to buy items including six
nintendo switches an apple tv and two
drones police say they found a total of
115 stolen items in his classroom and
couldn't locate more than 4 thousand
dollars of outstanding items andrea
fuentes soto is accused of creating at
least 16 accounts changing both her
first and last names police say they
found 35 items in her classroom
including kitchenware a 70 inch tv and
also an apple tv police say they also
found 27 items at her home including
toys and when they seized her cell phone
they uncovered text messages with her
husband anything else we need the state
to buy responses include a new laptop
lol and pop's power rangers and i hope
we don't get into trouble according to
metro numerous teachers were involved in
this conspiracy and they uncovered a
group chat between sixth grade teachers
joking about it this was last october
but in november after the website the
program runs through which is called
donorschoose started to notice something
might not be quite right and contacted
principal welling she emailed staff
stating i will not approve any more
donors choose that are not real names
then metro police and the nevada
department of education would be getting
involved and finally in july the case is
moving forward with three warrants for
olmsted fuentes soto and welling judge
susan bockham ordered that she be taken
into custody her bail set at the same
amount police say was stolen down to the
penny you were placed in a position of
authority in our community supposed to
be protecting our
state in our community's most vulnerable
children
i think that these charges are egregious
legacy sent us a statement informing us
four staff members were fired legacy
conducted an internal investigation and
is fully cooperating with authorities
we'll put that full statement at
8newsnow.com so far all three defendants
face conspiracy and theft charges mostly
felonies metro police say the
investigation is ongoing